every actor understands the huge
significance of being cast in a Star
Wars movie but how do movie stars
actually react when they learn they're
going to play in the world's most famous
franchise here's how these Star Wars
actors found out they'd been invited to
a galaxy far far away the story of Mark
Hamill's casting as Luke Skywalker is
often made out to be a typical Hollywood
fairy tale where the penniless actor on
the verge of giving up on his dreams
plans the audition of a lifetime head
while Luke Skywalker certainly was the
role of a lifetime Amal was no penniless
actor in fact he has taken to Twitter in
the past that has spelled a myth that he
was sleeping on his friend Robert
England's couch when England told him to
try for the role and in fact Hamill not
only had his own one-bedroom apartment
in Malibu at the time but his agents had
already set up on audition for him even
back in 1977 Hamill was insistent on how
mundane the process really was I
auditioned like anybody else and yeah
that audition process started in 1975 as
a joint casting call with Brian De
Palma's supernatural horror flick Kerri
Hamill was called back for a screen test
with Harrison Ford in 1976 and the rest
is history
the Empire had a network that was
capable of doing that I've heard about
it I'd know something well now you know
he's on the move he had a much time
Harrison Ford Star Wars story actually
is a little more of a fairy tale in 1975
when casting began Ford hadn't appeared
in a film with a theatrical release
since Francis Ford Coppola as the
conversation in 1974 he started working
as a carpenter to make extra money and
it was while he was fixing up Coppola
Sophos that he ran into George Lucas who
directed Ford in 1973's American
Graffiti neither thought much about the
reunion until Ford's friend and Lucas's
casting agent Fred Roos recommended Ford
stand-in as han solo with actors
auditioning for other parts according to
Ford he read with over a hundred
hopefuls before being told that he had
actually made it onto the shortlist
himself
Lucas's version of events seems to back
this up to want to do this you want to
stand and sort of read some parts
against these other parts so we can get
through this thing and he said yeah and
he started reading me read them better
than anybody else did of course Ford was
characteristically matter-of-fact about
landing the job saying they asked me if
I wanted to do it and I said sure why
not
while Hamelin board were finding plenty
of work but little name recognition
Carrie Fisher had nailed the recognition
but struggled to find work
her parents Debbie Reynolds and Eddie
Fisher had been a Hollywood golden
couple
and later a Hollywood scandal thanks to
Eddie's affair with Elizabeth Taylor
meanwhile Carrie Fisher had made a brief
appearance in shampoo in 1975 and at the
end of that year while on Christmas
break from drama school she auditioned
for Lucas and Kari director Brian De
Palma in her memoir Fisher recalled that
meeting and being called back to read
with for when her agent called to tell
her she got the part Fisher wrote he
laughed then I laughed and dropped the
phone and ran out into the front yard
and into the street it was raining it
didn't rain in LA it was raining in LA
and I was Princess Leia as happy as she
was to become Princess Leia however the
role did come with a few drawbacks they
asked me to lose at that point 10 pounds
because they thought it was a hole in my
face one person who didn't buy into the
hype around the original Star Wars
trilogy was Natalie Portman who'd yet to
turn two years old when Return of the
Jedi was released she was only 14 when
she was offered the role of Queen
Amidala in the Phantom Menace but she
had already found critical acclaim at 13
first as a trainee hitman and Leone the
professional and then later in 1995's
heat on the press tour for the Phantom
Menace Portman pointed out that she'd
never even seen the other films I really
wasn't aware of what Star Wars was at
all
far from leaping at the chance to be in
Star Wars Portman took some time to
actually consider the role before taking
it it took me a few weeks to decide by
doing this film because it's a huge
commitment to sign on for three films
when you're 14 Mike Harrison board
samuel l.jackson didn't entirely know
what he was getting himself into when he
met with George Lucas but as a longtime
Star Wars fan boy he was totally on
board nonetheless the two first got
together after Jackson went on a talk
show and mentioned that he'd like to
work with Lucas
soon after Lucas's people got in touch
and arranged to meeting he said I don't
know what you doing it you know and I'm
like look just make me a stormtrooper
yeah I just want to run across screen
nobody even used to know a few months
later Jackson said he got a call that
Lucas was shooting in London and he flew
out without even having seen a script it
was only when he arrived at the costume
fitting and was handed the iconic
robes that he learned that he was going
to be playing a Jedi Jackson also got to
choose his own lightsaber handle which
the prop Department inscribed with the
initials BMF I want you to go in that
bag Jackson later said that despite his
characters unpleasant fate and revenge
at the SIP he'd still happily make more
Star Wars movies even before being cast
as the sequel trilogy force wielding
heroine Trey Daisy Ridley felt like she
was in touch with something supernatural
and one of them 100 partly that doing
and you saw was film and I wishing my
whole body went tingly and I was like I
think I'm gonna get part in this film
psychic revelations notwithstanding it
still took five auditions with director
JJ Abrams for Ridley to land the role of
Ray still she was offered the role
nonetheless and only ran into trouble
when it came to actually accepting it I
checked my voicemail and there was a
voice bars like Oh God okay and then I
could didn't know how to call America
because I had never called America
unfortunately Ridley's hopes for an
immediate celebration with scupper I was
outside the theater and the play had
started and it was before he made six
figures playing Finn in the force
awakens John boyega was only really
known for indie alien thriller attacked
the block and his bank account reflected
his acting struggles in 2018 boyega told
an interviewer that he literally drained
his savings just to get a cab ride for
his final meeting with Abrams the good
news he got the part the bad news he had
no money to get a ride home once he
finally got home though boyega said his
immediate reaction was one of relief I
was I was looking forward to getting a
good night's sleep where I wasn't
contemplating whether my life would
change or not or whether I was gonna
work on a franchise however not everyone
at home fully grasped the importance of
the moment I was like that I've just
been costing Stahl was and he was just
like oh my god you are is ours that is
fantastic I knew it what is that was
before he was cast in Star Wars Oscar
Isaac was an indie darling who'd
appeared in a number of low-budget
movies that performed well both with
critics and at the box office for
example he showed up in drive and ex
machina
and played the lead in the Coen Brothers
inside the Welland Davis
however when Isaac was offered the
opportunity to star in the force awakens
director JJ Abrams had to convince him
to sign up for the Star Wars role Abrams
brought Isaac to Paris in 2014 for a
meeting at coffee shop and celebrity
hangout café de Flore and while they
were there Abrams revealed a lot of key
details about the project as Isaac
explained to vulture he basically told
me the whole thing the whole story it
was incredibly exciting just to be
called in and told that it was awesome
but Isaac was less enthusiastic about
playing the skilled yet rebellious pilot
poe dameron telling GQ I didn't know if
I could make it interesting after a few
days thinking it over he signed up but
wasn't necessarily fulfilled by the role
explaining I actually felt the most
green and insecure that I had in a long
time it felt weird and like I was not
being creative of course the experience
wasn't enough to put him off blockbuster
franchises in 2016 he played the
eponymous villain in x-men apocalypse
Adam driver was busy filming HBO's
critically acclaimed series girls when
it got the call about star wars and
drivers road to the role of kylo Ren
wasn't exactly run-of-the-mill
in fact driver clarified in 2016 that he
never even auditioned for the role
driver has also said that all that
waiting meant it took a while for it to
hit him that he wasn't just preparing
for any old film but a Star Wars film in
the end it wasn't until he found himself
surrounded by the movies costumes that
he realized what he was in for the new
characters and stormtroopers the new
updated version of them and that was the
first time that I was like all oh my god
the Star Wars while a few stars might
have professed and not being huge Star
Wars fans before they took the roles in
the franchise Gwendoline Christie was
all in on the series I wanted to be in
Star Wars my whole life you know I've
been a fan since I was six years old
when I first saw the film's The Game of
Thrones actor has said she pestered her
representatives constantly I was just
constantly going on and on and on about
it and and I would just every phone call
everything say oh they're interested in
you for this I want to be in Star Wars
like Adam driver in samuel l.jackson
Christie said that it really hit her
that she'd made it when she got to put
on captain phasma's metal armor and Kate
of course pre-phase MA her favorite
character was Leia and she also majorly
banned girl Dover
Carrie Fisher she is different she's
unafraid she's smart she's brave she's
bold
she's unashamedly herself domhnall
gleeson learned that he'd landed the
role of general Hux the day before the
force awakens now-iconic first table
read in January 2016 shortly after the
force awakens was released Gleason went
into detail about actually taking on the
role of Hawkes they said that he wanted
power and he was intent on getting it
that he had a cool speech evidently that
pitch totally convinced Gleeson you want
to do so if that's different to what
you've done before and you want to be
part of things which are really good but
Gleason did have some misgivings about
the fame the role would doubtless bring
him he explained fame as the end goal
for a lot of people but it is not mine
I worried that the accompanying fame
would get in the way of how I live my
life it got a little crazy for a couple
of months and then it died down
Felicity Jones wasn't quite built for
battle when she was cast as rogue one
street-smart rebel gin or so in fact she
was most famous for playing Jane Hawking
in the Stephen Hawking biopic the theory
of everything which had earned her an
Oscar nomination but few fighting skills
my immediate reaction was that I have to
do a hell of a lot of fitness and fight
training in order to play this
incredible leading character Jones
credits her agent with introducing her
to the role telling people my agent said
there's a fantastic leading female role
in the upcoming Star Wars that I think
you're really going to love that was my
first encounter with Jin in typical top
secret Star Wars fashion Jones met rogue
one director Gareth Edwards at 5:30 in
the morning to discuss the project and
Jones said she knew she had to take the
part when she read the script as she put
it
it's one of those once-in-a-lifetime
experiences when you read a role like
that I was just like I have to do this
even after taking the role it took a
little while for the enormity of it all
to sink in but Jones loved working on
the film even the intense battle
sequences as the actress explained there
was much joy in being a part of it
before she landed the role of Rose in
the last Jedi kelly marie tran was
working full-time in a temp agency by
day
occasionally fitting in auditions when
they came up and writing comedy sketches
by night in an interview with
Entertainment Weekly she admitted the
whole
process was beginning to wear her down
she explained when I turned 25 I had
been at it for some years and I was
struggling to pay my bills I was tired I
would get up at 5 a.m. and then I
wouldn't be home until 11 p.m. the days
were like that for years the auditions
for the last Jedi took five months which
sadly meant that quitting her day job
wasn't an option in fact on the fateful
day that she learned she'd been cast in
the film she had to meet with director
Rian Johnson on her lunch break and of
course once she found out that she had
the part she had to keep it a secret
Tran explained so I went back to work
and answered phones and answered emails
like nothing happened it was the most
bizarre experience inside I was like ugh
crazy by far the cast's biggest Star
Wars nerd Laura Dern has admitted that
being in Star Wars was pretty much the
dream of a lifetime I was a little girl
about two blocks from here at the
Cinerama Dome was the first time I ever
waited in line to see a movie being Star
Wars but when director Rian Johnson
first pitched during the idea the exact
nature of the role didn't quite register
where is it in small-town america early
he's like no no no it's Star Wars I was
like for a while during thought he was
speaking metaphorically about her
character until Johnson finally admitted
that he pulled her in to talk about Star
Wars but once she got the set Darren
felt the full force of her new role I
got to set and they rolled camera and I
opened my eyes and they called action
and I was staring at c-3po and I started
to cry check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite movies are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]